[Musique]
l'industrie automobile touchées de plein
fouet par la crise du coït 19 pour
soutenir le secteur le gouvernement
prévoit un plan de relance au menu prime
à la conversion bonus écologique des
solutions qui rappelle celle de 2008
au début de la crise financière l'état
est prêt à tout faire pour sauver
l'industrie automobile décembre 2008
avec la crise des subprimes le secteur
automobile est au plus mal
moins de crédits accordés baisse du
pouvoir d'achat les ventes de voitures
neuves s'effondrent - 14 % seulement un
mois ce pas dacourt agence capa ce
trophée secteur clé de l'économie
française l'industrie automobile fait
alors travailler un salarié français sur
dix préserver cette activité est donc
crucial pour le gouvernement le 4
décembre 2008 nicolas sarkozy présente l
une de ses mesures phare
une prime à la casse va être instaurée
pour inciter les français à renouveler
leur véhicule surmontant sera de 1000
euros pour tout achat d'un véhicule neuf
émettant moins de 160 grammes de co2
l'objectif relancer les ventes et ainsi
maintenir la production et la
distribution automobile française
l'ancien pdg de renault carlos ghosn
accueillait la nouvelle avec soulagement
cette prime à la casse qui a été
annoncée pour un an va permettre selon
nos prévisions qu'au lieu que le marché
français par exemple l'année prochaine
soit -15% ses précédentes prévisions
eh bien il sera probablement moins 5% ça
va permettre d'amortir un peu la
récession mais du côté des usines et des
sous traitants les avis étaient plus
mitigés salariés ça va rien changer à ma
vie croît c'est peut-être faire ça pour
essayer d'amadouer un peu les gens mais
bon
françois grand chose car depuis
plusieurs années déjà l'emploi dans la
filière automobile française est
fragilisé par les délocalisations et
primes à la casse ou pas rien n'allait
changer selon ce délégué syndical en
2008 le prix du coût du travail dans les
pays de l'europe de l'est s'est claqué
les actionnaires sont tentés de
s'expatrier pour d'abord au moi j'y
crois pas trop que je pense que plus
continuer quelque chose
fin 2010 la prime à la casse s'achève
l'heure est au bilan l'objectif de
relancer les ventes de voitures et
atteint plus 7,7 pour cent en deux ans
en revanche les effets sur l'emploi en
france sont discutables
les petites voitures dites entrée de
gamme ont été les plus vendus et selon
une étude 55% d'entre elles ont été
construites à l'étranger
[Musique]